[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le 7-8 week-end nous allons parler
actualités mais aussi loisirs voici les
titres de ce vendredi 26 février
retour sur l'atterrissage réussi du
rover de la nasa persévérance sur mars
des éléments embarqué sur le robot ont
été fabriqués dans les yvelines
focus sur l'entreprise 3d plus de buts
notre invité également pour en parler
franck mon médecin spécialiste de mars
et directeur de recherche au latmos de
guyancourt
nous parlerons également d'une idée
originale une colocation pour personnes
âgées
une mère et son fils vol la créer d'ici
2022 à ecully enfin nous vous
proposerons aussi les idées sorties et
loisirs de ces yagg est son go avec de
l'accrobranche et du jardinage
juste avant cela le premier ministre
jean castex s'est exprimé sur la crise
sanitaire jeudi soir vingt départements
sont désormais placés sous surveillance
renforcée
toute l'île de france et donc les
yvelines cela veut dire notamment que la
part des contaminations aux variantes du
coc vite 19 est supérieur à 50%
le gouvernement se donne une semaine
pour décider si un confinement le
week-end sera mise en place ou non
autres annonces la vaccination des plus
de 65 ans devrait démarrer à partir du
1er avril et à quelques jours d un an du
premier confinement le 15 mars dernier
on s'en souvient le directeur de cabinet
du préfet des yvelines thomas la vieille
sera l'invité de l'émission le club de
la presse présentée par wilfrid richy
une émission à retrouver à partir de ce
samedi 27 février sur notre site
internet tv 78 points comme est sûre
dans trentaine dimanche 28 février à
16h45
également dans l'actualité un dépistage
massif est organisé ce week end à
chambourcy
cela fait suite à de nombreux cas
positifs aux variants sud africain et
brésilien du coc vide 19 détectés au
sein des groupes scolaires de la commune
comme l'indiquent la directrice
départementale de la r
ce marion chine ali sur twitter le
dépistage aura lieu au gymnase georges
gallienne samedi 27 et dimanche 28
février de 10 heures à 18 heures et la
rs a également formulé une
recommandation celle de reporté la
rentrée scolaire d'une semaine au lundi
8 mars prochain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
partons du côté d'une autre planète à
présent retour sur l'atterrissage du
réussi atterrissage réussi du rover de
la nasa persévérance sur mars jeudi 18
février dernier
nous en parlerons dans un instant avec
notre invité franck mon médecin
spécialiste de la planète rouge
avant cela dans ce rover des composants
ont été fabriqués dans les yvelines
exemple une caméra fabriqués par
l'entreprise 3d + abus qu elle va
permettre d'orienter le laser pour
effectuer des prélèvements
les précisions de nicolas landry elles
ont fait le tour du monde les images de
l'atterrissage du rover persévérance sur
la planète mars
ce robot piloté par la nasa est un
concentré de technologie c'est le cas de
l'instrument super cam fabriqués en
france
sa caméra prochainement en service a été
produite par trois des plus une
entreprise située dans les yvelines
elles permettent surtout d'orienter le
laser pour savoir où le lazare sera en
train de
de tirer ce qui va créer une poussière
de la roche qui va être pulvérisé par le
laser et puis les images ont été
récupérés par la caméra et permettre
d'analyser quelles sont les éléments qui
sont à l'intérieur de cette poussière
amélioration de la qualité de l'image de
la performance des composants
électroniques 3d plus est spécialisé
dans la production de ces technologies
satellites de télécommunication
d'observation ou rover depuis 1995 cette
société consacre 90 % de son activité un
l'industrie spatiale persévérance pour
nous c'est pas une nouveauté dans la
mesure où on était déjà sur le rover
précédent qui s'appelait curiosity
l'enjeu pour nous c'est mettre à la
disposition des scientifiques nos
meilleurs savoir-faire pour qu'ils
puissent va voir l'instrument dont il
rêve pour essayer de découvrir l'origine
de la vie sur mars
ça permet de tirer nos technologies vers
le meilleur de ce qu'on peut faire et
puis après les autres produits plus plus
classique je dirais vous envoie en
bénéficier dans les prochaines semaines
persévérance va commencer à utiliser
cette caméra fabriqués à buc 3d + a déjà
en ligne de mire la prochaine étape de
cette mission martienne
ils vont collecter des échantillons et
donc faudra les ramener sur terre donc
ça c'est deux ou trois missions les deux
ou trois missions suivantes voilà qui
commence à être en préparation
et puis par ailleurs non à d'autres
activités mon plus classique 1 sur des
satellites d'observation de la terre
pour la météo la surveillance du climat
ou des choses comme ça 270 salariés
travaillent au sein de cette entreprise
elle réalise 70 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires pour continuer à
parler de cet atterrissage réussi sur
mars nous accueillons notre invité
franck mon médecin avec nous en
visioconférence bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes planétologues
spécialiste de mars directeur de
recherche au cnrs au laboratoire
atmosphères observations spatiales
latmos il est situé à douille en cours
et plus précisément à l'université
versailles saint quentin le latmos a
donc participé à la conception des
éléments que le rover persévérance à
emmener sur mars
l'un des éléments c'est super calme le
latmos a développé une partie de
l'électronique du spectromètre
infrarouge ir est
qu'est ce que doit faire ce spectromètre
d'un médecin alors c'est un spectromètre
qui est une nouveauté
sachant que l'instrument super cannes
c'est l'évolution de la rue manque ncab
la mission de rover précédente et
nouveautés et qui inclut la capacité de
regarder la lumière diffusée par les
roches martiennes dans l'infrarouge et
c'est cette lumière peut être
interprétée en termes de composition
moléculaire et donc de remonter la
minéralogie et en tant que spécialiste
de cette planète rouge très mystérieuse
et en tant que scientifique également
j'imagine que vous étiez quand même
satisfait de l'atterrissage réussi de
persévérance sur mars
qu'est ce que vous ressentez lorsqu'une
mission se passe comme cela en disant
ces missions qui est dans la partie
finale extrêmement complet ce complexe
et qui requièrent vraiment des prouesses
technologiques pour arriver à ses fins
et donc toujours une femme dans boîte
parce que quand on voit le le
cheminement depuis la terre jusqu'à
l'arrivée près de mars
je suis les sept lignes de terreur
connaît maintenant on est on est on est
très très anxieux vers une libération de
savoir que leur peur s'est posé sans
souci parce que a priori on a passé les
étapes les plus dures et le nord-est
après la phase la phase scientifique
dans la télé et là c'est vraiment un
outil d ingénieurs de la nasa
il a passé et la phase scientifique elle
concerne aussi le cratère j'ai zéro donc
c'est le cratère où s'est posée
persévérance ils étaient remplis d'eau
il y à 3,5 milliards d'années
quel est l'intérêt de se poser en ce
cratère l'intérêt finalement
scientifiques en particulier dans ce
cratère des roches assez spécial depuis
leur
donc on a beaucoup de satellites qui
tourne autour de mars et qui ont permis
de faire
justement ces relevés minéralogiques en
orbite c'est un des instruments en
question c'est un argument qui était
développé à l'université d'orsay oméga
et ce team aston a permis de savoir que
dans le cratère il y avait à la fois des
roches carbonates et aussi des roches
argileuses et ça c'est vraiment le
témoignage d'une activité d'eau liquide
passé et il ya probablement rester père
elle pendant plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'années et donc on peut
imaginer comme ça s'est produit à un
moment donné où la vie est apparue sur
terre que cela aurait pu voir émerger
une forme de vie assez assez élémentaire
mais néanmoins elles présentent toutes
les j'ai raconté les bonnes
caractéristiques pour s'y intéresser dit
alors le latmos est sûre et sur le
devant de la scène internationale en ce
moment il ya eut lu vs q ca de cette
mission avec ces nano satellites de
space x qui a fait beaucoup parler du
latmos dernièrement
hélas le latmos participe également à
d'autres missions finalement sur la
planète rouge
alors je le rappelle il a la
responsabilité de l'instrument spicam ce
qui survole mars depuis fin 2004 et
aussi l'instrument chem cam qui opèrent
à bord du rover curiosity depuis août
quels objectifs pour la recherche
scientifique pour le latmos en
particulier qui nous concerne cadbury en
cours sur avec toutes ses missions sur
mars
aujourd'hui petit correctif dit
magistrat de rio city c'est l'instrument
sam dont il est question quel calme
néanmoins même si son curiosity et qui
est pas moins important est en fait le
latmos est intéressé à plusieurs
disciplines dans le cadre de
l'exploration de mars
on va particulièrement timide spicav au
latmos j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur le
l'atmosphère l'admr ce qu'on essaie de
d'améliorer notre connaissance sur la
composition de l'atmosphère de
comprendre comment elle fonctionne comme
un sens qu'elle dise ce qu'elle nous dit
un terme de
deux problématiques de ce qu'on appelle
des chaperons c'est à dire comme en mars
a perdu au fil du temps c'est son
atmosphère et puis des gens des
collègues pas très loin de mon bureau
travaillent eux sur la plus tôt la
recherche de matières organiques avec
cet instrument de deux positifs et on
est positionné sur tout un tas de
missions en fait je n'ai pas beaucoup
mission c'était l'heure n'est pas parce
que justement d'un panel d'expertisé au
niveau scientifique qui nous permet de
nous insérer dans beaucoup de missions
différentes
merci franck monter sans long mais c'est
un pardon d'avoir été avec nous en tout
cas aujourd'hui sur direction et
quevilly désormais c'est un projet lancé
par une mère et son fils une colocation
pour personnes âgées devrait voir le
jour d'ici 2022 dans la commune la
maison déjà acquise par la famille et
pour leur entrave aux investissements
prévus quatre cent mille euros
reportage de justin brasier et agathe
perry avoue une colocation pour
personnes âgées à ecquevilly c'est le
projet de nathalie et mehdi
objectif proposer des services et une
surveillance 24 heures sur 24 tout en
continuant sa vie normalement une
alternative aux ehpad
c'est une forme de all inclusive où les
personnes donc seront locataires de
leurs chambres meublées et aussi
partageront les espaces communs vous
avez pas mal de personnes qui vont en
ehpad parce qu'elles ont peur de la
solitude et du coup ces sept personnes
entre rester chez elle toute seule et se
retrouver en ehpad enfin il ya la maison
des baies avec services pour la
nourriture les animations sortir et ça
chez vous tout seul c'est difficile de
reproduire ça la maison des b sera
composé de six chambres
un projet qui fait écho à une histoire
personnelle ma maman en fait en 2019 qui
a fait un avc et les médecins préconisé
l'ehpad on a lutté pour qu'elles
n'aillent pas dans un ehpad
elle est rentrée à domicile on a mis en
place tous les services nécessaires et
on a vu en fait qu'elles progressaient
énormément pour l'heure la maison est en
travaux les deux membres de la famille
seront soutenus par le dirigeant des
artisans bâtisseurs pour la partie
technique
il y en a un grand dirigeant qui va être
fait il faut donc gérer toute la partie
administrative
il faut gérer aussi la partie technique
les parties des fondations et tout ça on
a vite fait de se tromper et de faire
des erreurs
d'autant plus qu'il va y avoir à
l'intérieur puisque c'est un élément qui
reçoit le public d accès particulier il
va y avoir des règles particulières et
qu'il faut les mettre en musique avec
l'ensemble des corps de métiers acquise
en juin dernier la maison est situé au
24 rue des vignes à ecquevilly le
service ce devrait être mis en place des
bus 2022 budget prévu quatre cent mille
euros
comme chaque vendredi si agathe congo
nous propose ses idées sorties et
loisirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine nous allons prendre de la
hauteur la crau campe de saint germain
en laye a rouvert le 13 février dernier
depuis le parc d'accrobranche ne
désemplit pas il vaut mieux même réservé
à l'avance patrick jacques de dixmude et
astrid bergère sont allés faire un tour
regarder avec un beau soleil samedi 20
février la croquante de saint germain en
laye a fait carton plein presque toutes
les places étaient réservées la veille
c'est-à-dire plus de 207 parcours
d'accrobranche et sont disponibles il y
en a pour tous les goûts en fait quand
vous venez ici on vous répartis sur les
parcours en fonction de votre taille de
votre personnalité si vous êtes plutôt
craintif plutôt à l'aise ou plutôt
téméraire
comme on dit on vous êtes accompagné du
début jusqu'à la fin
dans le choix des parcours dans
l'initiation sur les parcours
d'entraînement et dans les différentes
activités qu'on propose ici ne partirai
sans il a été ouvert en 2010 1009
l'accrobranche n'est pas la seule
activité possible sur le site
on essaie de s'inscrire dans une
démarche éco responsable donc on propose
des courses d'orientation des jeux sur
le thème de la nature anniversaire team
building et stages qui peuvent durer de
deux jours à une semaine
le parc est accessible à tous ses
activités en extérieur permettent de se
retrouver entre amis ou en famille
vu que les restos sont fermées et les
bars on ferme et on s'est dit que
c'était la seule activité possible à
faire en plein air on voulait réserver
en fait finalement ce matin mais c'était
au complet donc on s'est dit qu'on
passerait tout simplement sursis
directement voir s'il y avait de la
place au final
on est bien tombé on a besoin d'être
libre dans l'ailleurs chose qu'on n'est
pas sur terre aujourd'hui donc le fait
d'être fois dans l'herbe assez bien on
s'en libérer tout roule actuellement
donc ça fait du bien au mental mais
parcourir à plus tôt cette semaine à 10
heures pour accueillir davantage de
clients après l'accrobranche nous allons
parler de jardinage miquel et demi
d'euros le journaliste a la main verte
nous a rejoints bonsoir vous allez nous
parler du jardinage en cette fin d'hiver
alors tout à fait c'est bien c'est une
période plutôt délicate quand on veut se
lancer dans le jardinage vous rappelle
qu'il ya deux semaines il faisait des
températures négatives dans les i mean
avec de la neige aujourd'hui fait
presque 20 degrés une période vraiment
traumatisante pour les végétaux mais il
faut se lancer dès à présent dans le
jardinage pour avoir un magnifique
jardin des milieux avril on écoute
etienne désir le paysagiste il est
également gérant de la boutique les
jardins de la vallée à magny les hameaux
tous se préparent en hiver au printemps
c'est le feu d'artifice tout parent
feuilles
on récolte ce qu'on a semé un peu en
hiver en fête voilà maintenant on est
dans les derniers temps de l'hiver donc
on a encore moyen de rectifier le tir
entre guillemets on l'a compris il faut
commencer à jardiner dès à présent mais
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire localement il
faut bien nettoyer son jardin pour cela
on va utiliser un râteau il faut bien
enlever toutes les mauvaises herbes et
les feuilles mortes ainsi sur ce point
car sinon on ne peut pas repartir sur de
bonnes bases
on peut ensuite se lancer dans des
plantations mais pas n'importe lesquels
on écoute etienne désir nous donne des
conseils on va commencer à planter on va
bientôt voir arriver
dans les jardineries les vivaces les
graminées aussi qu'ils sont des plantes
qu'on va avoir tendance à planter enfin
de en fin d'hiver pour pâques elles
pourrissent mais surtout on peut finir
encore planté quelques arbustes voir
quelques arbres et pour ceux qui ont
encore un peu peur de changements de
température à lens par exemple 10 degrés
la semaine prochaine on peut quand même
planté etienne désira nous rassure
certains végétaux ont pu très légèrement
gelé le feuillage
on va les rabattre très légèrement ce
qui va permettre de créer une réaction
sur le végétal qui est de lui permettre
de repartir de plus belle
voilà mais les petits gel que qu'on a
eue il ya rien de dramatique en fait
j'espère que je vous ai convaincu ce
signal et pourquoi pas faire du
jardinage ce week-end oui oui mais
justement j'ai du temps libre j'aime et
mais je vais m'y mettre et je vais
pratiquer vos conseils
merci mais qu'elle fournit des
précisions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis la crise sanitaire la culture se
fait en ligne et les bibliothèques de
versailles n'y échappe pas elle non plus
un site dédié aux collections
patrimoniales poète rimogne halde vient
d'être créée
il se nomme la sirène nous recevons
aujourd'hui vincent égalé bonjour
bonjour vous êtes donc le directeur de
la bibliothèque municipale eu de
versailles en ce moment vous avez
plusieurs expositions sur votre site
internet
est-ce que vous pouvez m'en parler alors
c'est un portail qui est tout neuf qui
vient en complément du portail que nous
avions lancé l'année précédente qui
était déjà issus de la réforme at ease
ation de l'eau de notre catalogue et
donc c'est ce portail patrimoine qui
s'appelle la sirène est en fait une
extension de notre patrimoine match et
permet en effet à la fois donc de
consulter le catalogue classique avec
notamment sur un focus sur les
collections patrimoniales et aussi
découvrir toute une gamme de services
donc les documents numérisés qui sont
attachés aux notices de ce catalogue est
entendu des expositions virtuelles des
présentations pédagogiques donc des
supports qui peuvent aider un certain
nombre de facteurs de la culture je
pense notamment aux revenus de mon corps
enseignant et des expositions virtuelles
comme vous l'avez dit dont la nôtre
dernière qu'il était présente et donc
physiquement à la bibliothèque centrale
avant que nous soyons obligés de tours
est fermée lors du deuxième confinement
est donc que l'on retrouve sous cette
forme maintenant que j'espère que nous
serons d'ailleurs versé au fur et à
mesure les supports des expositions
précédentes qui avaient eu lieu pour
cours
et peut-on consulter des documents
anciens par exemple alors oui si on peut
consulter les documents anciens qui sont
numérisés alors attention ne sont pas
tous ça prendra des années parce que
nous avons des centaines de milliers
d'ouvragés de deux pièces de collection
donc vous pouvez commencer à découvrir
sur la sirène un certain nombre de
pièces parmi les plus emblématiques
notamment
je pense par exemple aux fameuses
courses de test et de bagages était le
grand carrousel des rois de 562 donc des
mises en scène par charles perrault avec
de très belles enluminures à la main
donc voilà il y en a pour tous les goûts
toutes les formes si j'ose dire
et en fait évidemment c'est un outil qui
destiné aux chercheurs mais pas
seulement si vous souhaitez voir mais
les images nous avons aussi un instaurer
une carte interactive en quoi ça
consiste
et bien cette carte vous avez la carte
de versailles
et lorsque vous avez des documents
concentrent en lien avec une rue un
bâtiment bien vous pouvez retrouver des
photos anciennes des cartes postales
extérieur en surtemps gens s'écartent et
alors qu'est ce que l'atelier numérique
alors l'atelier numérique ça n'a pas
grand chose à voir avec la stiren
l'atelier numérique c'est bien un
endroit physique qui fait partie du
réseau des bibliothèques de versailles
le réseau c'est donc neuf bibliothèques
en tout sur la ville
et parmi celles-ci l'atelier qui est un
peu le petit dernier qui était donc qui
était lancée en 2016 qui en fait une
sorte de mediatek prévoit notamment qui
qui permet à la fois de se former aux
outils internet donc toulon c'est que
toute la population n'a pas un accès
égal
déjà à internet et en plus pour pouvoir
donc faire réparer son ordinateur à
suivre une session de formation
apprendre à utiliser les outils
justement que nous que nous créer à
l'intérieur de la bibliothèque
mais pas seulement et puis voilà toutes
sortes d'ateliers alors aujourd'hui on
essaye de les faire en ligne puisque on
ne peut pas recevoir physiquement les
personnes du moins pas rentrer autrement
non l'atelier numérique propose aussi
des sessions de jeux vidéo on est plus
jamais mais moi j'en ai peut-être
d'autres projets sont à prévoir
alors les projets oui nous en avons bien
sûr déjà on va continuer à numériser nos
collections les plus importantes celles
qui le méritent
et puis nous allons continuer à
implanter du des supports du contenu en
fait nous avons de très bons outils la
sirène et tire son nom d'un ancien
bateau qui se trouve dans notre
bibliothèque centrale à bateaux du
xviiie siècle un bateau c'est comme un
sessini comme il faut il faut qu'on me
remplissions justement c'est cette coque
donc bâton élevé au fur et à mesure on
essaie d des éléments qui vont pouvoir
enrichir notre base
et puis ce que j'espère aussi ce sont
peut-être des contributions par exemple
de chercheurs que nous pourrions mettre
en valeur notamment sur nos livres les
plus rares en avons quelques exemplaires
uniques notamment dans notre notre
bibliothèque du 16ème 17ème siècle donc
le pouvoir justement faire partager une
recherche avec le plus grand nombre la
scène où tout change vraiment à quelque
chose qui serait de l'ordre
merci beaucoup 20 en guinée d'avoir été
notre invité merci à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour finir cette page loisirs je vous
propose une activité pour ce week end
avec une animation de jeu d'échecs pour
les enfants de 5 à 15 ans proposé par
l'association sports et loisirs des
bréviaires samedi 27 février de 14
heures à 16 heures ils pourront
s'initier à l'échec et mat ou faire des
tournois dans la salle des fêtes de brie
des bréviaires un protocole sanitaire
sera mise en place et de 7,8 week-end de
continue avec eléonore pour parler de
l'actualité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'actualité de la semaine c'est mélanie
poké qui vous la résume en 78 secondes
[Musique]
une visite dans le cadre du projet de
loi climat et résilience oran verger
rapporteur du volet consommation et
michel edouard leclerc se sont rendus
dans une grande surface du groupe ce
lundi le plan france relance concerne
aussi le patrimoine de préfet de la
région ile de france marc guillaume
s'est rendu au moulin de saint cyr
l'école et à l'école nationale
supérieure d'architecturé de versailles
deux projets à 9 et 30 millions d'euros
à saint germain en laye le quartier de
l'hôpital va se voir transformer
jusqu'en 2026 le clos saint louis est un
projet d'écoquartier 5000 m² de
commerces et 450 logements sont
notamment prévus après un tournage le
week-end dernier la révélation du clip
le rappeur ni longtemps car tu as acheté
un morceau sur tracts une réponse à
l'emballement médiatique après les
propos du professeur de philosophie
didier le maire les gendarmes aux côtés
de la population rurale du département
dans plusieurs communes et militaires
investissent des bureaux pour recevoir
les habitants et c'est un effet
inattendu de la crise de lakovic 19 plus
de vingt mille entreprises ont été
créées dans le département des yvelines
en 2020
[Musique]
votre rendez-vous légal checking
aujourd'hui retour sur les arrêtés anti
pesticides on écoute vincent couronne
fondateur des surligneurs
plusieurs maires ont pris il ya quelques
mois des arrêtés anti pesticides
interdisant sur le territoire de leur
commune l'utilisation de ces produits
nocifs pour la santé
sauf que ces arrêtés sont illégaux et
certains ont en effet commencé à être
annulée par le juge car l'autorisation
des pesticides relève de la compétence
nationale et pas locale
l'arrêté pris par le maire europe
ecologie les verts de grenoble eric
piolle n'a pas encore été annulé mais
l'édile voit bien venir le jugement sans
trop se faire d'illusions eric piolle a
donc décidé de prendre les devants en
prenant un nouvel arrêté cette fois ci
anti déchets en considérant que les
pesticides sont un déchet j'espère que
vous me suivez
pour comprendre il faut savoir que si
les pesticides ne sont pas de la
compétence du maire les déchets eux ils
le sont le petit tour de passe-passe du
maire de grenoble pourrait alors
fonctionner sauf qu'il existe une liste
officielle des déchets une liste fixée
par la commission européenne et que
cette liste est bien ne contient pas les
pesticides
il peut s'agir de déchets issus des
pesticides les emballages par exemple
mais pas les pesticides eux mêmes et
comme le principe en droit c'est que les
actes de l'union européenne prime sur
les axes nationaux et donc a fortiori
locaux et bien l'arrêter andy déchets 1
du maire connaîtra le même sort qu'on
prévoit pour son arrêté anti pesticides
l'annulation par le juge
la morale de cette histoire vous trouvez
le droit amusant mais ne vous amusez pas
avec il s'en rendra toujours content
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 week-end merci
de l'avoir suivi une très bonne soirée
un très bon week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]